ouais runnin runnin première chose que j'ai entendu dire
que vous étiez surpris quand vous avez entendu
que le répéteur voulait vous parler
très surpris ouais excité parce que l'une
de nos émissions de télévision préférées
chaque fois que nous les autorisons à entrer au
Royaume-Uni c'est du gluten c'est juste que ça fait
partie du  épreuve du décalage horaire
ouais, il semble toujours y avoir la
nuit où nous entrons en ville et vous
ne pouvez pas dormir et c'est à peu près la
seule chose qui vaut la peine d'être regardée, donc vous savez que
nous sommes comme regarder le
snooker international se propager sur le snooker et puis d'
accord B na  s'allume et nous sautons de haut en
bas et le pedo est quelque chose comme
ça pourrait se comparer en Amérique il parle
de musique Ed Sullivan Show American
Bandstand vide il n'y a rien qui a
la variété de rapido et la
qualité bien
donc les choses sont la première raison pour laquelle je voulais
filmer dans une chambre d'hôtel, c'est parce
que c'est là que c'est ta maison la plupart
de l'année où la plupart du temps
c'est ton armée mm-hmm c'est incroyable tout ce
que je voulais être ici  fonctionne bien même si je
pense oh s'il vous plait
plusieurs allez dormir bonne nuit Non
maintenant les choses sont propres ouais les choses
vont se passer très vite aujourd'hui ouais je veux dire
les disques ne sont sortis que depuis deux
mois ou quelque chose quelque chose s'est passé
ouais je ne sais pas  c'est juste un flou je
pense que cela fait environ trois mois maintenant
après le 24 septembre c'est vrai
trop c'est trop
oh il y a une perception du temps et de la
réalité est évidemment que cela a commencé ces
je veux dire un album un album à faire pas
la première fois que je '  Je leur ai permis d'aller
vous savez dans leur main dans le Bilbo en
essayant le Topshop et le numéro quatre
qui est très rapide c'est aussi rapide que vous
pouvez obtenir n'est-ce pas Je n'ai jamais prêté
attention aux graphiques avant ouais vous savez
je veux dire les chiffres juste  juste un tas de
statistiques vraiment je veux que ma
carte soit faite carte astrologique afin que nous puissions
aimer notre prochaine version ou aimer ma
vie personnelle je vais aller comme ma carte dit
tu sais que je suis un Taureau tu sais que Saturne est
en Sagittaire et moi  chanceux et
diamants bleus  et les stars du porno et les stars du porno de trèfles verts à
propos de Luke Diamond, il y a les
diamants, je suis sûr que vous vous sentez même si vous
ne regardez pas les chiffres, certains des
autres vous recherchent d'autres numéros
maintenant, je suis sûr que je veux dire ici chaque
torpille  te parle beaucoup les gens
te parlent veulent bien te parler
tu dois retourner en Amérique ça
va être pareil tu sais comme un numéro
pour eux c'est un très gros album et puis les
gens vont vouloir parler  votre
opinion sur tout ce qui se
passe déjà hmm ouais nous avons nos opinions
nous sommes un tas d'avis aidid jerks laissez-
moi vous dire boulette saccadée saccadé c'est si
difficile d'avoir une opinion sur
tout quand vous demandez c'est difficile
d'avoir appe sur tout parce que je
je ne sais rien sur quoi que ce soit
bien je n'ai pas donné ton opinion c'est
quelqu'un qui est juste ton opinion je veux dire
ce n'est pas l'évangile ou quoi que ce soit toutes les opinions
sont ouvertes au dialogue et
donc si vous pouviez vous appeler cette
pression déjà bien vous savez
être abattu d'être tiré à une
pression de tapa mm-hmm je ne pense pas que
nous ne prêtions pas vraiment assez d'attention je
veux dire que ce n'est pas comme n'importe qui euh nous ne nous sentons pas
responsables de sortir et d'essayer deux fois plus
fort toi  sais, je veux dire, c'est juste qu'il se trouve que
nous avons fait ce que nous faisons et si
cela monte au numéro moins 12 sur le
graphique et au numéro passé quel que soit le
numéro passé un à moins 12, ce n'est pas
grave, vraiment,
je pourrais vous apporter cela  la
conversation sur l'exposition et la pression
n-non je suis malade je suis malade
bien tu as appelé la flûte anglaise je
pense que tu peux le faire frire Egon cette fourchette j'ai
frappé dessus c'est vrai hey tu n'as pas de
front tu as un  La tête magique à 8 têtes à
8 têtes va juste apparaître sur
OH
c'est comme ça que nous planifions notre destin avec
cette boule à 8 magiques vous savez que vous la
retournez dit essayez à nouveau vient et dit
oui oui
tu sais que je tiens le je te fais  pense quand
tu vas retourner aux États-Unis
quand tu dois retourner en
Amérique comme deux semaines Decem  ber 15
euh-huh
et puis on part en tournée encore cinq
jours puis on a un mois de congé et on va
en Australie Nouvelle Zélande Hawaï Japon
comment je mange j'aime l'Asie du sud-est et puis
on fredonne un petit moment c'est
dingue parce que  Je peux Francine comme non
c'était par exemple d'où vient l'émission
d'où je viens personne ne
parlait vraiment de toi avant que quelqu'un soit
comme l'album de l'année tu sais comme
sortir à la télé tu sais c'est comme
tous les magazines un album par morceau
de l'action c'est ce que je
dis sont la première question ça va
très vite
c'est très en marche demandez si je peux brancher
un autre groupe que j'aime totalement quand
vous jouez quand vous jouez dans les
pays européens je ne sais pas si vous parlez aux gens
mais nous devrions surveiller les réactions,
mais bon, c'est la principale différence
entre votre foule américaine et la
couronne européenne, probablement les régimes que
les gens que je ne connais pas, j'ai en quelque sorte
trouvé que la langue est en quelque sorte
différente, je veux dire c'est  une  Tous ces gens
ont les mêmes réactions, vous voyez ce que je
veux dire, je suppose que nous venons tous d'un
ancêtre commun comme Adam et Ève Adam et Ève,
le créationniste droit Adam et Ève,
des créatures de type humanoïde évolutionniste
sont sorties d'Afrique et ont peuplé la
terre et je suis adapté  à leurs climats,
mais je pense qu'il y en a, il y a un
million de similitudes et il y a des
dissemblances et je pense que la réaction des gens
à la musique est une très grande
similitude, que ce soit sur le
continent,
que ce soit au Royaume-Uni ou que nous soyons en Occident,
vous savez si vous  allez à l'est ou si vous
allez aimer le Cambodge ou quelque chose qu'ils
ne sauraient pas quoi penser de vous
parce qu'ils n'ont vraiment pas été exposés
mais à l'ouest le rock and roll a été une
chose culturelle majeure au cours des 30 dernières
années donc  c'est à peu près la même
réaction, c'est aussi parce que votre musique
semble être basée sur l'instinct et alors les
gens peuvent être sûrs que nous n'aurions pas d'
importance si nous parlions en
langues  d qui n'aime pas
les clichés usés, vous savez que le rock and roll
est un frère de langage universel,
mais dans une certaine mesure, c'est vrai, je veux dire,
mais les gens, vous obtenez beaucoup de gens
dans la même pièce, vous obtenez un bon
groove et les gens vraiment  réagir c'est une
bonne chose mais c'est quelque chose d'autre
je ne me répète pas en Amérique mais
en Angleterre ou en France c'est comme si nous
récemment c'est plutôt cool d'aimer à
nouveau le rock beaucoup de gens sont sortis du
rock pendant longtemps  pour na et ils
portaient des vêtements noirs et vous savez juste si
c'est le cas, je veux dire que la musique n'est pas un
accessoire de mode, juste beaucoup de
gens, je le sais, mais pour nous, ce n'est pas le cas,
je suis dans la danse industrielle maintenant  vous
savez si ils disent aller au
prêteur sur gages et vendre tous leurs CD ce n'est
pas des disques à voir parce que les disques sont
sortis c'est peut-être quelque chose parce que des gars
comme vous aiment peut-être donner toute la nuit
à Brooke hmm
si le rock and roll mérite un  bon nom
ça le fait je pense ouais mais pas de Bon
Jovi donne  j'aime une mauvaise réputation
Dieu a donné le rock and roll Dieu vous a donné le rock
and roll j'ai un cadeau ça
s'appelle le rock and roll rock et Lowe a
payé beaucoup de liftings et de
greffes de cheveux il y a une chose que j'ai
apprise sur le rock  et rouler en étant dans
ce métier pendant cinq ou six ans
est d'utiliser votre illusion un et deux
dépend de ce qu'est l'illusion la vie est
pleine d'une fin perdue et voici ma
magie d'amour c'est magique c'est que je veux dire que le
rock and roll est bon je  Je dois admettre que ça
m'a juste fait traverser des moments difficiles
J'allais serrer dans ses bras sa maman ne m'a jamais donné
comme malentendant avez-vous entendu l'
histoire que votre femme Shelly a racontée aujourd'hui
à propos de la fille que Laurel la
fille qu'elle est le total regarde ça  Dora
pourquoi c'est ça c'est génial cette
cousine de 13 ans de Shelly a eu ses
pieds au cours des deux dernières années a
eu ses murs couverts d'affiches New Kids on the
Block et tout ce qu'elle a entendu tu vas me manquer aux
poupées tout ce qu'elle a entendu notre album
Peu importe et elle a déchiré tout ce qu'il  r des
affiches et brûlé ses poupées ouais elle devrait
savoir Stacy
Stacy est comme un petit morveux comme non non
c'est comme AE
New Kids on the Block il est une terreur
elle est une larme en lui elle fume des
cigarettes elle a un tatouage ouais
c'est vrai elle prend juste le  voiture maintenant
vous savez même assez vieux pour conduire
elle est juste un zip dans notre conduite musicale de
haut en bas ivre l'a traînée dans les gens
ce flic l'a tirée dessus elle juste au moment où
elle l'a frappé l'a assommé 13:13 c'est pas
grave papa aimer beaucoup de  les
gens aux états-unis  pour commencer, bien sûr,
je cuisine par le mot cheveux vous savez
comme oui oui dommage c'est dommage c'est comme
ça mais voir les gens euh ils doivent
utiliser ils font ils font des priorités vous
savez souvent une priorité est une voiture
dans  votre allée si vous savez
quels objets matériels vous avez et
c'est tout un tas de bibelots de bric-à-brac et de bibelots de
Bob ouais regarde cette
pierre brillante tu sais pourquoi est-ce plus
que c'est un Ming Voss pour moi je sais que cela
pourrait être je veux dire Elizabeth Taylor devrait
porter ça à son doigt
quelle est la différence ouais nous nous sommes
rencontrés sans faire une
déclaration aussi radicale ou nous avons vu une généralisation
les gens de votre âge vous les
verrez changer parce que je ne sais pas que
la jeunesse d'Amérique  l'autre sagesse est
plus difficile c'est un bon dossier les enfants sont beaucoup
plus intelligents je suis totalement convaincu que l'
un moyen plus intelligent est beaucoup plus
intelligent qu'ils ne l'étaient quand j'avais 18 ans
tu penses donc je suis convaincu tu sais je
ne me demande pas
bienvenue petitesse euh ils sont juste m
Plus conscients qu'ils sont plus blasés et cyniques,
ils sont plus conscients de l'injustice qu'ils ont
apprise de leurs parents.
sais et j'étais jusqu'à ce que les deux
soient bons non plus aucune telle chose comme une femme craintive je suis
sauvage est partie parce que maintenant Fairless ta
maison des serveurs et des serveuses dippy
te chantant joyeux anniversaire gamin tu as déjà
eu un de ces zoos un zoo oh ouais Jim
a un zoo était  comme 32 sortes
de glaces différentes ou 16 ou quelque chose comme ça,
j'ai pensé à une autre idée pour la
vidéo des singes de mer flottant dans le
filet vidéo, ce qui signifie que ce n'est pas n'importe qui
parce que vous savez quand vous parlez de
cynisme, je veux dire cette chanson l'eau
étant un cynique  n'est pas une bonne chose, je veux dire
que c'est le contraire non,
mais c'est un bon mécanisme de défense
et cela ne signifie pas nécessairement
que les gens évitent les
sujets nécessaires et les choses qui comptent vraiment,
cela signifie simplement que th  Ils sont conscients
du nombre de fois que les gens doivent
apprendre la même leçon,
eh bien, tout ne devrait pas être du
bon sens de toute façon.
J'ai
été comme si REM ouvrait les portes
des portes commerciales pour qu'un groupe comme
vous entre et ait un succès commercial
hmm un peu, je pense que chaque groupe
qui est en quelque sorte va juste le long de la
ligne a agi un peu corrigé ou
ouvert
si c'est comme toi ouais sonic toi
Jane's Addiction ils l'ont fait j'ai toujours
pensé à moi j'étais considéré comme un
commercial été en premier lieu
il s'est avéré qu'il y avait un bon
groupe commercial passionné et il y a toujours
eu de bons passionnés  groupes de rock and
roll à travers l'histoire, c'est
juste aux fans et aux personnes impliquées dans
l'industrie de la musique de s'assurer que cela
ne nous donne pas un passé et aussi mauvais
qu'il l'a fait au cours des 10 dernières années, en
particulier dans le Reagan  ère ouais ai-je
roulé trop serré alors on dirait ouais
peut-être quelque chose de bien comme du je ne
sais pas le mot est juste mais de l'
affiliation à un groupe traditionnel à propos de est-
ce que tu y arrives tu en parles tu
sais que tu as demandé une cotisation  beaucoup de gens,
vous êtes le premier à ouvrir la porte
ouais, il semble que le courant dominant
soit très cohérent, comme
fade moins d'être fade comme des
émissions de télévision ennuyeuses fades des groupes ennuyeux fades des
films à succès ennuyeux tout est très
cohérent quand il s'agit de  comme le
courant dominant et le commercialisme, c'est un
peu comme si personne n'était prêt à prendre une
chance parce que c'est un risque d'argent, vous
savez, c'est pourquoi vous avez eu le même
tas de conneries sur MTV au cours des six dernières
années ou quoi que ce soit d'autre, je veux dire
juste  se résume à l'argent et les gens
ne sont pas disposés, vous savez que ce n'est pas
faisable, voyez le mouvement commercial, vous savez que c'est
un cercle vicieux, c'est en fait ces
gens qui essaient de
gagner de l'argent, ils jouent vraiment
prudemment et ils prennent comme un
enquête démographique afin qu'ils enquêtent sur tous ces papal
papal la hiérarchie papale au Vatican
je veux dire qu'ils enquêtent sur tous ces gens
et disent comme qu'est-ce que tu aimes qu'est-ce que
tu veux voir et ils ont été nourris d'
ordures donc c'est tout ce qu'ils savent et ils
disons que nous voulons plus d'ordures, alors ils
lui ont à nouveau fait une enquête sur les ordures et ce sont
toutes ces ordures la prochaine chose que vous savez que vous
avez cette décharge pleine de
couches et de styromousse et qu'une
culture dominante est une couche chouchoutée souillée
dans un Big Mac  conteneur si
vous parlez d'un Hollywood
par exemple, vous savez parce que cela
coûte tellement d'argent pour faire un film et
c'est un risque comme quand vous parlez de
risque commercial ce qu'ils font maintenant
dépend depuis quelques années est-ce qu'ils
achètent avec succès  Les films français des années 50
et des années 40 qui étaient des blockbusters
parce que vous êtes où où font les
colorisés
et puis euh les laitages ils devraient
les aimer pour le bébé dans la voiture vous
savez mais ce n'est que le début  est-ce que à la
fois sortir et acheter comme oh ouais
c'est exactement pourquoi il y a tant de nouveaux
groupes populaires qui font des reprises de chansons même
il y a cinq ans, vous savez comme cette
bannière avec laquelle nous avons joué sur Top of the Pops
hier soir, nous faisons une reprise de  une
chanson de Christopher Cross
ouais ouais tu sais grincheux ouais tu aimes
trié ouais ouais c'est je veux dire combien de
fois dois-tu voir le même I Love
Lucy blot je veux une sitcom tu sais mais
il y a de bonnes choses là-bas je veux dire les
Simpsons je veux dire c'est  comme une grande
grande émission de télévision,
c'est un succès très initial ouais c'est qu'il
y a beaucoup de substance là
-bas parce que parce que je suppose que vous savez que
les lignes sur les murs sont assez
épaisses, il peut y avoir plus épais qu'ici
entre vous savez entre les gens y a-t-il
déjà un  étant des gens qui vous disent
de vous vendre parce que votre publicité ne
s'est pas vraiment produite, dites la
vérité, vous savez parce que nous ne jouons pas vraiment le
jeu, je veux dire que nous ne sommes pas bons,
nous ne sommes pas au Studio 54 avec Bianca
Jagger ou cruisi  En descendant Hollywood
Boulevard avec Slash et Mickey Rourke,
vous savez, je veux dire, ce n'est tout simplement pas vraiment notre scène.
pense que c'est
euchre dit avant je ne lisais pas
courir pendant la période de blanchiment que j'espérais que
j'avais peur de faire de la musique pop oh ai-je
dit que
bon ce qui est imprimé de toute façon j'étais plutôt
gentil mmm sent comme une citation erronée maintenant j'ai
toujours aimé  la musique pop c'est juste qu'il
se trouve que euh la plupart des signes que
nous avons écrits à l'époque de l'eau de Javel que
je sortais nous sommes des chansons plus abrasives euh
il y a pas mal de chansons qui étaient
très pop comme la chanson comme à propos d'une
fille
ils ont juste été laissés sur l'album en
fait quelques chansons très pop sur cet album
ont été écrites à l'époque sinon avant
la sortie de l'album de blanchiment et je pense
que la sortie du single sliver est un
bon exemple de ce que peu importe
aurait donc  parlons de  pop
parce que vous savez que chaque personne a
une définition, je suppose que l'Angleterre a
terminé pour une façon de parler de
poppers pour vous comment je suis alors qu'est-
ce que c'est que la pop pop est comme Rubber
Soul Beatles juste une sorte de chanson avec un
crochet très simple rien avec  répétition
ça n'a pas besoin d'être propre et jangly
oui
il y a quelques chansons de Melvin qui sont
pop à mes yeux mais je pense que la pop pourrait être
comme des chansons pour enfants
popping et
comme dans populaire ce n'est pas le cas mais les
chiots Neela voient aussi quelque chose comme en
Angleterre c'est certainement le cas est
quelque chose que vous aimez écrire
parfois remarquez des chansons pop que vous
cachez vraiment mais vous savez qu'elles sont juste
là-haut et  et tu travailles avec lui
et tu sais que je pense que c'est ce qu'est la pop
en Angleterre comme une publicité télévisée dans ce
jingle de bâtons ouais n'a-t-il pas euh richard
carpenter fait ça des charpentiers il a
vu euh une publicité de banque parce que j'ai vu le
L'histoire de Karen Carpenter et il
regardait de la pop télé et des quaaludes que sa
mère l'a allumé pour entendre Richard qui a fait
éclater leurs quaaludes, ils vont vous calmer
alors il fait éclater des quaaludes en transpirant euh
et il a vu cette publicité télévisée pour une banque
et cette chose va nous  Je viens juste de
commencer, il dit que c'est un succès, alors il a mis sur
le cor un Herb Alpert et par le
droit d'auteur de cette chanson, puis ils ont eu
un million de vendeurs et s'il faisait encore des
ludes